they were asked what scientific evidence
do you have that care fuse could stop
the spreading of kovid you know what
they came out with a public opinion poll
that's the science they had and they
said look peop this is what people want
so
that's not science i understand there's
a methodology that is scientific but
that's about it it's political science
that's what frightened people want when
you ask ask them stupid questions that
they answer impulsively when they've
been frightened specifically and and
pointedly by their governments in
collusion with the idiot legacy media
that they're subsidizing
[Music]
oh hello everyone i'm pleased
to be talking today
with mr eric du m and he is the leader
of the conservative party in the
province of quebec
the
french language dominant province
in canada
and
he is the fourth
or the fifth
conservative leader to speak with me
on my platform
over the last year or so
a process that's actually been
accelerating in recent months
i've spoken with a number of the
candidates who are vying for the
leadership of the conservative party in
canada at the federal level the
conservatives for those of you who
aren't canadian
or who are canadian but don't know
the conservatives and the liberals at
the federal level in canada
battle continually have battled
continually throughout canadian history
for
the leadership position and generally
it's the liberals who
win
although the conservatives perhaps
occupy the throne so to speak about a
third of the time and so the basic
political landscape in canada is
center right versus
center left
and we have a socialist party the new
democratic party
that also
shows reasonably well federally and
they're
farther left uh generally speaking and
for most of canadian history that's been
the balance at the federal level there
are additional parties
playing a federal rule but they're
relatively minor players
now and historically
generally in canada over
our entire history which is since 1867
formally although the country in many
ways goes back hundreds of years before
that
all the parties have been
credible
players and likely to do
approximately what they claim they'll do
in
in some fundamental sense which means
they're no worse and maybe no better
than generally
respectable and responsible human
enterprises and that's enabled canadians
to
develop and maintain a fair bit of trust
in their fundamental institutions and i
would say that trust has been shaken
quite profoundly in the last five or six
years on in a very large number of ways
one of the consequences of that is that
the relationship between the political
class and the media class has shifted
quite dramatically
the legacy media everywhere in the world
is
dying a relatively painful death as
network broadcasting becomes an
untenable enterprise and as
the proliferation of online publishing
platforms has led to the demise of the
dominance of centralized print
journalists and all of that shaking out
in all sorts of odd ways
one of them is that
the legacy media increasingly colludes
with people in power
but also
and
and logically following from that no
longer serves its role as proper critic
of
democratic leadership let's say
and so
the political class in canada
particularly on the conservative side
seems to be waking up to this reality
perhaps because they're treated worse by
the legacy media than the other parties
more unfairly because of the left
leaning bias that characterizes the
legacy media and so
one consequence of that apparently is
that these leaders have been
increasingly
willing
to talk on youtube and then more
specifically to talk with me
um
and
recently mr duane reached out to me
he
is the leader of the conservative party
in
quebec and
wanted to engage in a long-form
discussion which i think is a very good
thing given that
it's a form of political discussion that
isn't filtered through
arbitrary editing or
the necessary process of parsing out
trenchant sound bites and so it's
actually possible to have a discussion
that involves thought
that also isn't a competition between
the journalists which would be me in
this case and the and the politician so
i'm going to give you a bit of a bio of
mr duane and i'd like to thank him for
having the well for being willing to
speak with me and for having the courage
to submit himself to
a long-form discussion in public because
that's not nothing to do that it's uh
it's quite a
daring form of self-exposure to do this
without
pre-preparation and
none of the questions that i'm going to
ask him were agreed upon beforehand
there's
there's no tricks here except for the
ones i can't help but play
so i'll give you a little bio about mr
duhame and then i think probably what
we'll do is
we'll try to situate
the political landscape we'll try to
describe the political landscape in
quebec and to situate that
within the broader political landscape
in canada so that people who are
listening have a sense of what's going
on there and we'll also
attempt to describe why knowing such
things well first of all should be
relevant to canadians obviously but
might also be relevant to people around
the world who
increasingly at their political level
especially in the west are grappling
with very similar problems it's a very
weird convergence around the world of
of the assemblage of problems and
potential political solutions so
mr duan earned a bachelor of arts in
political science from the university of
montreal and a master's degree from
ecole nationale de ministration public
he writes for the journal to montreal
he's had a long career as a journalist
and the national post which is one of
canada's national newspapers and works
on various non-legacy journalistic
endeavors online and elsewhere he's one
of the early adopters in canada on the
political horizon of the non-legacy
media forms like the podcast that we're
engaging in at the moment he spent
more than a decade as a political
advisor in ottawa canada's capital and
quebec city which is quebec's capital he
advised stockwell day a leader of
one of canada's conservative parties
which have now amalgamated by the way
when he led the canadian alliance from
2001 to 2004 from
mario de mont who was leader of the
axiom democratic to quebec from 2003 to
2008 and later jill ducep
of the block quebecois which
paradoxically and strangely is a
separatist party for quebec that
operates nationally in canada because we
have a very peculiar political system
to aim also co-founded the resolute
liberte quebec quebec a movement aimed
at a revival of conservatism and
libertarianism in quebec because
mr duhain
leans on the conservative side towards
the more
individualistic libertarian
end of the
distribution
in november 2020 duane ran
to succeed conservative party of quebec
leader adrian d puglio winning
with 95 percent of the vote
and so i thought we'd start our
discussion first by welcoming you mr
duane and then get letting you uh
expound for a bit on
maybe you can explain
quebec
to
to to our listeners what
let's talk about the province a bit and
and about its
interesting situation in the canadian
political landscape and then we'll talk
about the current
quebec political landscape and what
you're endeavoring to achieve
thank you very much for welcoming me uh
the uh well you want me to talk about
quebec for those who are not aware of
course where the
the the the french province in canada
the
you know 20 25 23 of
of canadian canadians we um
you know we've uh
politically speaking over the last 50
years quebec has been a battleground
between the separatists and the
federalists so there's a those who
wanted quebec to separate from canada
and those who wanted quebec to stay
within canada for many decades
you know since i was born we've always
been fighting between those two uh
political sides and now the political
landscape is changing in quebec slowly
but surely there were two defeats for
the yes side so for the separatist side
in 1980 and in 1995 and that's where
probably many people all around the
world heard the most about quebec
because it was a very very uh tight
result especially in 95 whether it was
like not even 51 against 49.4 percent so
that's been a you know a huge political
uh
thing going on but nowadays there's not
as much appetite especially not among
the youngest generation to talk about
those divisive issues were elsewhere and
we see that the two old parties that
used to split uh us between federalists
and separatists the yes camp and the no
camp are melting down and now we have
five political parties you know it's
very very unusual for the kind of system
that we're in um and so there's five
main political parties in this upcoming
election at the provincial level there's
one socialist party quebec solidaire
there's the governing party the
coalition of quebec which is a
nationalist centrist party there's a the
liberals who are the the former
federalist side who are still
federalists but uh
uh more leaning on the left as well and
the separatist party historically with
the party quebecois who's also more on
the left of the political spectrum so
it's gonna it's a very very interesting
period of time in our history
politically speaking and this election
could be a very historical election that
is going to mark the end of a cycle and
hopefully the beginning of a new one
we'll be back with eric duham in just a
moment but first let me tell you about
helix sleep
getting a good night's sleep is one of
the most important things you can do for
your health that's why helix sleep
provides tailored mattresses based on
your unique sleep preferences the helix
lineup includes 14 mattresses each
designed for specific sleep positions
and preferences
side sleeper models with memory foam
layers offer optimal pressure relief
stomach and back sleeper models feature
a more responsive foam to cradle and
support your body plus helix mattresses
offer enhanced cooling features to keep
you from overheating at night
don't compromise on comfort take the
helix sleep quiz and find your perfect
mattress in under two minutes
helix mattress ships straight to your
door free of charge try it for 100
nights risk free go to helixsleep.com
jordan take the helix sleep quiz and get
up to 200 off your mattress order plus
two free pillows that's helix sleep dot
com slash jordan for two hundred dollars
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows
a canada's been a somewhat difficult
country to cobble together because of
the linguistic divide because of the
massive scale of the
of the geographic enterprise
and because of the distinction and
differences between the
french
civil law system and the english common
law system and so it's been a real
tricky balancing act for canadians to
keep the country unified from coast to
coast with quebec sitting not precisely
in the middle but approximately in the
middle and so
um as mr duane said that just about came
to destruction twice in the last
45 years uh is we escaped with our
country intact by the narrowest of
margins
um it might be of some interest for
people listening to know that in many
ways and please correct me if if you
believe my interpretation to be
incomplete
quebec was one of the last countries so
to speak
nations in the western world
that underwent the transition from
uh
traditional catholicism
to
to the to modernity
the
the the awakening in quebec let's say
occurred in the late 1950s before that
quebec was an extremely
traditional catholic enclave with
extremely large families i did genetic
research in quebec for quite a long time
and it was very common for the older
people in our research samples to have
had
10 siblings very large families
and then
and so quebec
was
united on the french side
and very tightly kin-related because
quebec was also settled by a relatively
small number of french settlers and so
quebec was also a tightly kin related
society and the french
were
were under the rubric of this intense
catholicism
the english in quebec had more financial
power generally speaking although they
were a very small minority of people
compared to the french
in the 60s
catholicism dissolved precipitously
church attendance plummeted family size
crashed to the point where
in many recent decades quebec has had
one of the lowest birth rates in the
western world the marriage rate
collapsed and along with that collapse
interestingly enough
there was a real rise in nationalism and
to me it's always been okay the case
that
that was sort of a microcosm in many
ways of what also happened in europe as
classical christianity deteriorated
other
systems of group fostered belief
flourished and part of what drove quebec
separatism was in some real sense a
substitute for the religious
impulse that had united quebecois before
i talked to a gallup pollster
probably 20 years ago he answered a
question i always had
been curious about he said that their
research had indicated that if you were
a lapsed catholic
in quebec compared to a a continual
church-goer let's say and someone who
maintained their faith you were five
times more likely to be an advocate for
separatism
and now mr duhames pointed out that in
recent years and that would be post 1995
when we had the last referendum on
quebec separatism the quebec separatist
cause has
attracted less and less
fervor especially among the young and
you mentioned to me in a bit of a brief
conversation that we had before this
podcast started that
you're actually the conservatives have
actually started to become
more popular
they're showing their greatest growth in
popularity among people who are
relatively young in quebec which is
really not what you'd expect so maybe
you could explain a little bit about how
you see the relative demographics and
positions of the various political
parties in quebec
well first off i want to talk to you
about the the as you rightly pointed out
the uh what we call it here was the
quiet revolution in the late 50s early
60s when that shift happened when the
catholic church lost control after
certain extent of what was going on in
quebec and uh where the the nani state
became
you know growing and growing that's been
happening for the the last 50 years so
the uh there was a complete shift and
quebec didn't do anything different from
other societies except that it was done
much faster like we it was a fast track
of everything that we observed in the
western world we did it in a very short
period of time why so probably because
we're more homogeneous
people and so that's probably why the
shift happened so quickly um and that
being said the
the impact politically uh as you said
was that the the anglophones who were
dominant you know economically speaking
uh well
there was a shift on that side as well
with the growth of the nationalist and
the separatist movement and i want to
make sure here that we differentiate
nationalism and separatism in quebec i
define myself as a nationalist which
means that i you know i'm proud of being
francophone i do believe that the common
language in quebec is french and i think
that even anglophones agree with that
here in quebec there's one million
non-francophones in quebec uh who choose
to stay here and the profile of those
people today has is very different than
the one we had in the 60s or 70s uh the
english community to give you an example
75 of parents who have kids at school
here in montreal and elsewhere in quebec
who are non-francophones 75 of them now
send their kids to a french school uh
immersion programs or bilingual schools
you know so they want their kids to be
bilingual and to grow in french and in
english
so it's it's not it's not french against
english and i think that nowadays my
nationalist my nationalism is positive
like i see anglophones as allies to to
keep our uniqueness in america as a
french society
i don't see them as a threat i don't see
them as enemies
and and that's but i'm a nationalist
like i i do believe i don't i don't
believe that quebec should become
english and we should assimilate that's
not the point here so it's very
different to say we want to break up
canada and we want to completely
separate and have it our own and saying
we want to promote french and when you
want to become quebec premier as i do uh
you have to understand that one of your
first duties is that you're not just the
leader of a province like elsewhere or a
state in the u.s you're also the
political leader of the french minority
in america there's no one politically
that has more power than you do and one
of your primary roles is of course to
promote and to protect french and and i
i i want to do that and i think it's
important for the quebec premier to do
that as well so um
that's on on the linguistic front
if i could say so the uh
the way that we see it and it does as
you said the youth as a different
approach because the
you know people who are i would say the
shift is between 55 and 60 years old
right now in quebec when you look at the
polls we're dominating it the latest
main street research was saying that
we're dominating between 18 and 50-ish
and then there's a complete switch and
then when you're at 65 and over it's
like 11 to 1 in favor of the cac the
government the governing party right now
in quebec so you see it's a completely
reversal and we're especially popular as
conservatives among people between 35
and 50 who still have kids at home those
people are the most hardcore
conservatives that you can find right
now in quebec so it's interesting to
look at the demographics but um
we have to understand also that were you
know post crisis and
the crisis changed the political
landscape as well you know you cannot
lock down a society for over two years
and think it's not going to have any
political impact uh the people who
suffered the most and who were the less
at risk
are now you know
politically intervening and expressing
their frustration at a certain extent
and that also explains why
we're particularly popular among parents
of young kids compared to seniors so
it's a
for a guy like you who likes to analyze
what's going on in societies i think
quebec is an interesting case because we
had in north america we were the most
locked down society right there's
nowhere else in the continent where
restaurants were shut down as long as
they were here where even the
construction industry was shut down
where even we
we had passports the longest time for to
show passports vaccine passports to get
in in
in restaurants or bars or gyms or we
where we
we had a careful uh the longest curfew
the most severe carefuls 50 000
quebecers
got uh got caught by the police were
either arrested or given
tickets for a fifteen hundred dollars
each on average so i mean we went
through a very very uh strong period the
government was the uh
the most severe at many extent and uh so
it's probably having a biggest political
impact so it's not surprising that you
see a political leader like me raising
as quickly as we did over the last year
because you know the government went way
way very far
with the authority and now there's kind
of a counterbalance of people who are
looking for a politician that respects
much more their civic rights and their
individual freedoms um so it's a it's a
counterbalance i think we are and i i
want also to point out one thing because
it's that's that may be of interest to
everybody as well here in quebec you
know we have never seen a political
party raising as quickly as the
conservative party has over the last
year when i when iran decided to run for
the leadership of the party less than
two years ago there were 500 members in
the party as we speak we have 60 000
members we're by far the largest party
in terms of membership we went from one
percent in the polls to
somewhere between 50 and 15 and 20
percent right now
um and we are the party that has the
largest amount of donors in quebec this
year we're now represented at the
national assembly because i convinced
one of the member of the cac to cross
over cross the floor and join us we're
going to participate in the leaders
debate we're i mean we're we're going up
very very quickly and uh we've never
seen that
usually for a political party it takes a
few elections to reach the point where
we're at right now for us it took us a
year and when you spoke about the media
the impact of the media
i just want to underline that during my
leadership race between november 2020
and april 2021
that i got one single article in a main
street newspaper a daily paper in quebec
it was in le devois when jose verner
senator decided to
to to support me and become the
president of my leadership race
and le devoir wrote an article which is
not the main daily paper
and that was the only article and at the
end of the leadership race i had 15 000
members i had more members than the
governing party of the the premier of
quebec
and not one single other media did talk
about us they didn't even acknowledge
our existence so it shows the shift and
it explains why people like you are more
more popular than complete networks now
and the uh it explains the the the
difference
and also the uh the
clash at a certain extent
in terms of media right right right well
i should also point out for the
listeners so i know quebec reasonably
well because i lived in montreal from
1985 to 1993 and i loved montreal and
for all of you who are listening
especially in north america where it's
easy
there is no better place on the north
american continent to visit in many ways
if you're interested in an urban holiday
than montreal montreal is a great city
and
i say that
[Music]
despite the fact that the province that
i grew up in alberta
is in many ways
the most
fra it has the most fractious
relationship in many ways with quebec
um partly because alberta is very
english in its linguistic traditions i
took french in school throughout my
entire life but
no one in alberta speaks french to speak
of and it's very difficult to pick up a
language when even your teachers can't
really speak it and there's no use of it
in public i moved to montreal
when
the separatist movement was really quite
strong and i moved there with my wife
who had a very difficult time obtaining
employment although she could speak
french reasonably well she was
anglophone and there were real obstacles
in her path i went to an english
university and so that protected me in
some sense from my linguistic the
consequences of my linguistic ignorance
but
i loved montreal and although i was not
very happy in some sense being a
westerner about quebec nationalism or
quebec separatism in particular one of
the things i did understand very rapidly
was that
part of this stunning charm of montreal
and part of what makes it unique
was a consequence
of the very real barriers that those who
were determined to protect quebec
culture had erected
around the
local institutions in
quebec and so one of the things that's
very interesting about montreal downtown
it's a very walkable city by the way it
has great restaurants and great
bars and an
unbelievably vibrant and safe and
dynamic and interesting and creative
street life and the montreal municipal
authorities have done a lovely job of
regenerating the old city and the old
port looks great and
montreal is just a wonderful city and
because of the barriers to
anglophone dominance that's the canadian
word for english dominance let's say the
city never became homogenized in its
corporate culture and there were a
tremendous proliferation of local
businesses
and that they all had all the charm of
local businesses so they weren't chains
of restaurants that were exactly the
same as restaurants everywhere else and
and so
despite the fact that these barriers
uh linguistic barriers made life in some
ways more difficult for me personally as
an english speaker and despite the fact
that i was somewhat irritated about the
fact that
the english had been routed out of
quebec in some fundamental way
and
that the relationship between alberta
and quebec was fractious i loved
montreal and every time i go back there
i'm thrilled to be there and it really
is a remarkably wonderful city and so it
begs the question you know when
how do you preserve the local
while maintaining integration with the
superordinate and we have that problem
in the world right now because the
world's increasingly international in
some real sense
there's a real
utility in preserving local culture and
at the town level at the province level
at the
state level at the national level to
preserve the
autonomy and
unique charms of each of those levels
but also to integrate the whole into a
harmonious union and all of us are
struggling with that in a major way and
canada struggles with that internally in
a way in some sense that mirrors the
situation in the entire world and so
that also complicates the political
landscape
and so now having said that you also
said that
and i
so quebec is also this very interesting
contrast
because
montreal is a very free city
uh
people
pursue their own artistic interests it
has a very dynamic
street life
people
people who live in montreal live there
it isn't a city that feels like it's
made up of people who move there
and
it's a very free culture but
quebec also has this other element which
exists in paradoxical juxtaposition
which is in some ways more authoritarian
than authoritarian in its proclivity
than any other jurisdiction in canada i
really saw that when i interrupt
interacted with the government at the
municipal level in quebec which was also
often breeding all sorts of regulations
that were just absolutely unreasonable
and that was hard to negotiate with and
you said that quebec like france
had
implemented extremely
stringent covid lockdowns which is so
much at odds with the spirit of a city
like montreal and you also pointed out
that that's bred a
desire for would you say a desire for
the more libertarian kind of
conservatism that
if i've got that right that you
represent and would like to make a case
for yeah the uh well you have to
understand that too as you rightly
pointed out earlier as well when we
talked about the fact that the religious
factor were you know was melting down
since the 60s their social conservatism
in quebec
is almost inexistent like you know
you know i'm the first openly gay leader
of a conservative party in canada's
history provincial or federal um so the
i mean that's and it's not a surprise
that it's happening here in quebec
because social conservatism is not part
of the coalition of conservatives uh
that we are we have fiscal conservatives
and more libertarian conservatives but
there's no there's not we're very few
social conservatives do you want to
outline the difference between those so
that everybody who's listening
understands so you said social fiscal
and libertarian um it isn't obvious to
people what the differentiation between
the various forms of conservatism is
especially because the legacy media
almost never talks about it so
fiscal conservatism is people who want
lower taxes smaller state uh you know so
that's generally speaking the how we
define fiscal conservatives uh social
conservatives are usually more uh
towards moral issues so uh it's more uh
you know gay rights or abortion or all
those hot issues that we hear a lot and
the the media talks about it a lot about
that normally when they talk about
conservatives uh and the third one is
the libertarian
it's the individual rights the respect
for
of civic rights of individual freedoms
so that's more the uh
the the aspect that the the part that
i'm i'm in but you know as a leader you
have to be representing all the the
wings within your party but uh
there's there's there's really three i
see three main uh
kind of conservatives in canada and in
quebec we only have two out of the three
that's what i wanted to point it out and
the uh so it's it might be a little bit
different than elsewhere because the uh
as even if it's it's a contradiction for
many people because they recall quebec
before pre-1960 which was the most
religious society with a lot of kids for
everyone and and uh and we went from one
uh
one side to the other completely and now
the you know the religious practices
here and are much slower and especially
among the youth and that's why our our
voters are even younger so it's a it's a
complete shift
as well so the uh the conservative
movement in quebec is different and
there's a there's a nationalist element
as well that's probably not existent
elsewhere in canada
of of people who want to promote and
protect french and our culture and our
uniqueness uh that is because that's
also conserving you know where we're
from and our roots and our heritage
so what is it that you're doing or the
conservative party is doing in quebec
specifically apart from
the reaction against the authoritarian
clampdowns
justified hypothetically by covid what
do you think that you're doing
that's working
let me give you an example one of the
things i found as i've toured around
and i suppose making a case at least for
certain conservative virtues is that
people
particularly young people seem to
respond very well to the idea that
there is an intrinsic meaning in life
and that intrinsic meaning
is not to be found in that in like the
hedonistic limitless
freedom that's characteristic of of an
impulsive life but more likely to be
found especially under conditions of
duress
in
as a consequence of adopting
the responsibilities of a
of a mature life and so that would be
well existing
to some degree in service for other
people especially the people that you
love in your family
accepting responsibility for
a marriage and a long-term relationship
and and
accepting responsibility welcoming it
for kids and taking care of your
extended family and serving your
community and this is all something that
conservatives can really promote and i
think there's an unbelievable hunger for
it because one of the things i've
noticed and i have discussed this
publicly a lot i pay a lot of attention
to my audiences and
everywhere i go in the world
if i make a case for the
the nexus let's say between suffering
which is inevitable and the meaning that
emerges out of the voluntary adoption of
responsibility
everyone
falls silent and that happens all the
time
and my sense of that is and this is part
of the reason why i think there's a
conservative opportunity that's
beckoning in a major way that you might
be tapping into is that
what conservatives have to offer young
people and that's the first time i've
ever seen this really be the case is
the meaningful existence that
characterizes
it's so absurd that it has to be said
that characterizes genuine maturation
and sacrifice on behalf of others like
as a real viable pathway forward
existentially and psychologically to
have the kind of life that enables you
to not be bitter in the face of
catastrophe and so
now
it's a paradoxical thing right because
apparently what you're offering on the
libertarian side is something like
freedom from authoritarian constraint
that's an odd thing in some sense for a
conservative to be offering but do you
see
why is it that
what you're selling so to speak what
you're promoting
is resonating
deeply among
younger people in quebec and how do you
conceptualize that from the perspective
of the development let's say of a
political vision which is something that
conservatives tend to struggle to do
we have to understand that historically
because we were stuck in the old debate
in the old constitutional fights and
feuds
almost all the political parties in
quebec were more center-left it was all
they were all social democrats and they
were all in favor of the nanny state and
that's why in quebec we had you know a a
bigger state that the state intervention
was much stronger than elsewhere and
even at the federal level we we used to
vote more liberal
and we uh you know it's
it's always been there was kind of a
consensus on that side and now that that
debate is over there's a new one that is
emerging and of course
the fact that it's new and the fact that
it's fresh and the fact that it's
different is attracting all already a
younger crowd because you you're not
you're not scaring them off they love
changing but there's also the fact that
i do believe that they're you know
because of the social media because of
the new world that we're in they're much
more open towards the
the world if i could say so and uh they
that's something you know they want to
be part of something also larger and
for that you need a little bit more
freedom and you you don't want to be
just limited to quebec and with the with
the state intervention everything is
limited to quebec everything is so there
there's a vision of looking outside of
the box i think that helps out a lot uh
the fact also and i'm i'm back to what
happened over the last two years who
suffered the most during those days you
know you and i probably you know i care
if you at 8 or 9 p.m it's not the end of
the world but if i were 20 if i recall
what i was doing after 9 00 pm when i
was 20 the impact was much larger on me
and i think they took
much more than seniors they realized how
how the state could
you know uh ruin your life at a certain
extent when they're pushing the envelope
a little bit too far and so that woke up
a lot of people a lot of people who are
completely apolitical it's not
necessarily people coming from other
parties that are joining us it's people
who used to not even vote not and now
they're card carrying members and their
volunteers on our campaigns are even
running for us so there there's
something very very different the
paradigm also has shift
on that side and um it's a um
you know for many of us we realize that
politics could intervene a lot in our
life and that's why we're standing up to
say look you know stay out of it there's
limits and that's why even the slogan of
our campaign is liberating
we uh we didn't know you can't translate
that perfectly in english but if we
translate it word to word it's free at
home uh so it's but
and uh and what it says is that you know
there's limits i i want to have to
control you we're talking about your
family your your unit so even our slogan
refers to that uh you know like the
state cannot cross
my my entrance door without my will uh
and uh the uh so
you know we want we want to go back to
give to to be empowered of what we're
doing without within our own houses and
uh
it's and and that for a new generation
is probably something that is uh
you know is more interesting and and
even worldwide right now we see that you
know our our parents were more
collectivists in many ways you know like
just when you were talking about the
separatist movement the separatist
movement
at the base was was was a collective
movement you know it was as francophones
as old french canadians
you know it had something very
collective and nowadays because of
social media we're a little bit more
individualistic i think at many extent
and you know we uh we yes we are
francophone yes we are quebecers but
we're also part of all sorts of groups
and all sorts of friends all over the
world and we unite based on different
issues than just our language or our
geographic uh limitations so the uh
it also has an impact on your political
reality when it's time to vote so
well you you can imagine that okay so
the quebec was united in some sense on
the french side under the catholic
church and then that fragmented and then
quebec attempted to unite
under the auspices of a collective
nationalism
and so and then one of the consequences
was that was that people were turning to
a powerful and unified state as a
vehicle for their dreams and that meant
that the state became
as it became the vehicle for those
dreams it also became more
intrusive in the ways that would be
associated with excess let's say
pretensions of benevolence and then
you're making the case that
that became the limitations of that
approach became radically evident to
young people when the state overplayed
its hand in the aftermath of the covid
pandemic and locked them down way too
hard and that woke up a generation of
young people to the dangers of the
overweening state even if that was
allied with some
desirable expression of nationalism and
group identity does that seem about
right yeah that's about that's about how
i feel it's like that's what we saw over
the last few months the last few years
here in quebec it's uh it happened
elsewhere as well it's not where we're
not unique in the world where it did
happen but i think here it hit a little
bit faster and stronger uh the so the
difference and that's why quebec society
is an interesting case because of that
because as i said we usually react
quickly and uh more
homogeneously than elsewhere and so from
a sociological perspective uh that's
what you can observe right now
so on the policy side so
let's there's a principle that governs
conservative thinking that's actually
derived from the catholic church and
then even more deeply derived from an
older biblical tradition based on the
old testament exodus story
that
proper governance
proper distribution of responsibility
should follow the principle of
subsidiarity and so the notion is and
edmund burke developed this as well it's
a very good notion and i think it's
correct it's one of the things that
attracts me in some fundamental sense to
conservative thinking which is that
well you can imagine a state where
there's a single executive who has all
the power and the people have none and
then you'd think of that as a tyranny
and that's obviously not desirable
and then you might think well what's the
alternative to a tyranny and you might
say well direct democracy
where the voice of the people rule
supreme and the leader must follow the
whims of the crowd but the problem with
that is that
it's not that easy to figure out what
the crowd thinks and the entire system
can fall prey to
suddenly arising poorly organized
deviant impulses and so
what the founders of the american state
did and many other states as well is set
up a series of intermediary structures
of power
let's say and so you could sort of list
them up hierarchically there would be
the domain of responsibility of the
individual there'd be the domain of the
responsibility of the married couple of
the family of the local community that
then the town then the state or province
and then the country and then
each of those levels would be
re requested to
take as much responsibility for what
they could at the local level
and the relationship between all those
levels should be governed by the
principle that if it can be decided
at a lower level
than it should be
and the reason that that's useful is
twofold one is that it's a really
good way of distributing of delegating
responsibility it's very efficient if
everyone plays their role the second is
this is another thing the conservatives
really have on their side you know if
the state does everything for you let's
say well in a sense you're secure
although you're not because you're
beholden to the
benevolence of the state and that can be
taken away arbitrarily but the downside
is
this is one of the downsides of
universal basic income proposals is like
well what the hell is there left for you
to do
if the state does everything for you
well you're secure but you're what's
your life then you have no purpose and
if the purpose of life and this is
another thing that the more libertarian
conservatives could be offering is like
imagine that the purpose of your life
isn't security and satiation because
you're not just an overgrown infant
imagine instead that the purpose of your
life is something like
responsible productive generous
adventure
and then the call would be
make space for people to manifest that
in the particularities of their own life
and then everyone has a real part to
play and no one in some real sense is
subordinate to anyone else like there'd
be a hierarchical structure and some
people like you would be leading at the
more abstract levels
but your power would be your authority
and your responsibility would be
properly delimited
and everything else everybody else was
doing all the way down the hierarchy
right to the level of running their
individual enterprise would in some
sense be
just as meaningful and just as crucial
and that strikes me as an
extraordinarily useful vision of
governance especially in the aftermath
of the covent fiasco
and and it's interesting because that's
something that you're right the
conservatives in canada have not
exploited as much as they could uh
because you're you know philosophically
we want power to be the closest to the
citizen as possible we we're supposed to
be party of decentralization
and especially with the quebec question
um
you know the conservatives should be the
party that is the closest to the quebec
aspiration traditionally because one of
the big problem in canada was that one
size fits all from ottawa and it didn't
fit in quebec because we were different
in many aspects for all sorts of
linguistic historical reasons
and so
many conservatives that i know in ottawa
are the most decentralist politicians of
them all on the national stage but
unfortunately conservatives have never
been it's never been a stronghold for
conservatism in quebec uh well not for
like a century but and and it's there's
a
it should be the opposite and when you
were talking about alberta earlier on
because where you're where you're from
originally the alberta after quebec is
the most decentralist province in canada
and we should be the strongest allies
but as you as you said
we're often at the
on opposite sides because for all sorts
of other reasons but philosophically on
in terms of decentralization and power
vis-a-vis citizen
were were the ones who share the similar
view like and we we should we should
always be on the same side and we should
not be a centralist and and look at
ottawa that didn't think that they know
best uh so the uh
and that's what i'm trying to propose as
well i think it will be important if we
can have a real conservative party in
quebec at the provincial level and it's
important because quebecers unlike other
canadians we do identify ourselves first
and foremost to our provincial
government more than the federal you
know the federal it's like having you
know our nationality is quebec and our
our passport is canadian so the the the
uh that's how we define ourselves and so
the most important government for us is
our provincial government because you
know all the main things education
health care and all sorts of things it's
provincial the federal government is
managing things that are very far away
from us international relations and the
army and and canada post but that's how
we see it like so that
the our sense of community is related to
the provincial government and in alberta
after quebec is the province where he
has have that as high as we do uh
there's a strong sentiment of
alberta first and um
the so if we have a tree a true
conservative movement in quebec that
could last not just for an election but
for a generation or two uh i think we're
going to see new uh
alliances between uh conservatives in
quebec and elsewhere in canada and it
could have a huge impact on the federal
level uh and as you said the the
dominant party historically has been the
liberals but if we're able to switch
quebec which has always been one of the
reasons why the liberals were much more
in power than than the conservatives
because the french canadian catholics
used to vote more for the liberals
historically it was more the catholic uh
the catholics were voting more liberal
um and and if if that shifts and if the
decentralists start to link together in
canada and those who want to have the
the power closest to them the subsidiary
as you as you talked about uh then it
could we're gonna reshape not just
quebec politics but canadian politics
all together well you could imagine
you could imagine a vision
that
made the case that
quebec has maintained its distinct and
valuable culture particularly reflected
i would say in montreal although quebec
city is also quite a remarkable place
and i don't know rural quebec as well
that it's the principle of local
autonomy that in some sense has
made that possible and that actually
what's trying to be protected in some
real sense
is that local autonomy which would be
the special flavor of
well the small business community in
quebec and the services that it manages
and the street life and the festivals
and the
and the food culture and the schwa de
vivre which is definitely present in
montreal and the safety of the streets
there's a lot of value in that local
culture and what quebec quebecois
presumed for the longest time and maybe
with some justification was that it was
necessary to centralize under a powerful
provincial government and the
nationalist movement to ensure
autonomy
on the cultural side but you could make
a strong case i think and this is the
case that you're outlining that
no
the long-term survival of
the uniqueness of local
francophone culture is actually
dependent on the delivery of maximal
autonomy
to the citizenry and the subsidiary
institutions and that would mean that
you could as a conservative you could
make a simultaneous call to the
nationalism that's part of the quebec
ethos and this desire for individual
autonomy that's emerging in the
aftermath of let's say the overreach of
the nanny state that's a nice vision
it gives everyone a place and and also a
role in
a role in living their life and
preserving their cultural institutions
responsibility up responsibly at the
same time
i don't believe that the state can
impose a language or a way of life okay
it's each of us who have to make those
decisions and
you know if if young the young
generation let's say like now they don't
want to talk about separation so even if
you wanted to push it's not because the
party quebecois is going to deliver 20
speeches a day that everybody's going to
become separatist and it's going to
happen overnight
you you can't do those projects if you
have that project if you have the youth
against you against yourself and
you know we we have to make sure that we
bring it back at an individual level to
make sure that you know
we're promoting the fact that you you
should speak french you should be
bilingual and it's working actually
at many at many levels quebecers
francophones and anglophones have never
been as bilingual as they are today and
you know that's that's a richness i mean
we're the most bilingual i'm currently
in montreal in the most bilingual city
in america uh and i think it should be a
richness but unfortunately for over the
last decade or half a century it's been
considered a source of division and
fights and uh
that needs to change we we need to and
and even if you say i'm bilingual it
doesn't mean that quebec is bilingual or
the common language or both languages
are equal on the territory of course
because we're a
small minority we need to make sure that
the common language remains french
but it doesn't mean that at an
individual level we cannot all be
bilingual and every parent i know in
quebec they all want their kids to be
bilingual you know my parents don't
speak english
and my but my mom was a school bus
driver and my my father it was a sheet
metal worker uh hard-working parents
perfect parents
but they didn't have the opportunity to
learn english and they sent me to a
kindergarten in english and they did
huge sacrifice to to make sure
that i was i had better tools in my
toolbox than they did and and i think
every single parent wants that and it
was not the state that imposed that to
them they made a decision as good
parents like all good parents do
everywhere
and and you want your kid to do better
than yourself
yeah and you should have the freedom and
to do that and the encouragement and the
space to do that because it is def well
you see this is happening in the u.s too
is that as the
nanny state and the radical leftist
incursion into
federal and state uh institutions
precedes a pace
where that's hit the most resistance is
on the
issue of parent rights and people are
pulling their children in the u.s out of
the
public education system at a remarkable
rate because
people will exp accept without protest a
fair bit of interference with their
lives on behalf of a hypothetically
benevolent but ultimately totalitarian
state
but they will not accept
the
um
propaganda
campaigns directed at their children and
so the reason i'm saying that isn't for
a political reason exactly it's to point
out the logic of the principle of
subsidiarity because
you should have parents making decisions
for their children precisely because
there's no one who is going to care for
children more than parents exactly and
if the state says it's it will it's
delusional because well how in the world
can an abstract organization
distant from
the children it's serving unrelated to
them
and not knowing them personally
possibly care for them in all their
individual particularity as well as
biologically related kin who are
immediately living with them that means
a preposterous assumption on all fronts
and people will definitely rebel against
that when their children are threatened
so
let me turn let me turn to a different
issue um
i'm also interested and i think this
might be interesting to our
international
viewers and listeners
now
quebec has a very unique political
culture and so does your
party
provincially now well
when is the election going to be held in
quebec that's the first question october
3rd
okay october so you're in the run-up to
an election now at the same time
um as some of those listening know
canada is involved in a leadership race
for the leadership of the conservative
party federally in canada so to become
prime minister in canada you have to
first rise to head
a political party that has a chance of
being elected in
a majority of seats and then if that
does happen and your leader of the party
you become prime minister and at the
moment
there are five candidates on the
leadership front
um for the federal conservatives and
i've interviewed three of them pierre
polyev
roman bauber and leslie lewis and i was
quite impressed with all three of them
they're they're quite different as
people they're very different in their
backgrounds but um
it seemed to me like the adults were in
the room fundamentally and they all had
a certain degree of expertise and a fair
degree of moral integrity um joshua
ray's people decided that i
um that they wouldn't talk to me for one
reason or another although i invited
them several times and i haven't been
as successful in my pursuit of scott
hsn's people
and that really has nothing to do with
him and perhaps little to do with me
it's just been circumstances
unfortunately
how do you construe the relationship
between your
party
provincially
and the
conservative party federally and the
other conservative parties in canada so
let's start with that how do you think
that balance should be established and
what are you hoping for on the federal
conservative front in relationship to
your aspirations on the provincial
conservative front
well first off you have to know that we
have no organic links like unlike
some other provinces there's no link we
we we're two completely separate
entities of course we have the exact
same name uh we're both conservatives
and we are
center right where you know we were
defined on the same on the political
spectrum we're not far away from each
other but there's no direct links that
being said uh for me the most important
part with to be part and you know as a
conservative within canada uh is to
build bridges with other conservative
parties provincially uh first and
foremost because i'm a decentralist i'm
an autonomous and i do believe that it's
important to reach out to those people i
think we have strong allies that quebec
has never exploited because you know
when you're in a separatist dynamic
where you have a party that is a very
very federalist party like the liberals
in quebec have been over the last few
decades and on the other hand you have
the separatists well the separatists
don't want to work with anyone in canada
even those who would like a little bit
of decentralization to make sure that
they they don't show that canada could
work you know
and on the other on and on the other
hand the federalists uh you know they
want they want to be perceived as pro
canada as much as they can so the more
central is they become the better so uh
we we there was no room for someone who
was trying to build bridges with
provincial parties to decentralize
canada when we have uh common goals uh
and and that's that's for me where i
want to go politically speaking who do
who do you see as okay so let's start on
the provincial front so
again for the international viewers
every canada is made up of an assembly
of provinces and
the political structure at the federal
level tends to be somewhat mirrored at
the provincial level so there are
federal conservative liberal and
socialist parties and there are
provincial
conservative liberal and socialist
parties and they're either tightly or
loosely affiliated in the manner that
mr duane just mentioned
you're interested in coalition building
at the provincial level
on the conservative side or with other
perhaps interested welcoming partners
who do you see across the political
landscape at the provincial level in
canada
that you would regard as
reasonable and probable allies with whom
you could build a more a tighter
confederation i don't think it's
necessarily just personalities or it's
also
provinces because as we said earlier on
you know your your home province is when
you where you were born in alberta it is
it's always been the the province that
has been asking for more power from
ottawa outside of quebec uh so their
natural allies on that front and it was
true even when renewed was there an old
quebec separatist premier his best ally
was peter lawheed at the time the the
alberta premier of of the time um and
and it's always you know
when you look at it objectively alberta
is probably the strongest ally of quebec
in terms of decentralization and i've uh
you know i'm a good friend of jason
kenny the current premier uh daniel
smith who's running for his leaders for
the leadership of the party is also a
close friend i've always had a lot of
friends in alberta among conservatives
and i think that the first province that
is normally and historically
an ally should be alberta well it would
be lovely to see that as speaking as an
albertan and maybe i can do a little
sideways move here
canada
is in a quandary
like the rest of the world
on the energy and environment front
and quebec and alberta have been at
serious odds on that issue for the last
decade as well as alberta and the
federal government and
the chickens in many ways are coming
home to roost i mean the german
chancellor came to canada a few weeks
ago cap in hand and asked his old ally
the canadians for help with liquid
natural gas provision for example to
help reduce this catastrophic german
dependence on
russian fossil fuel exports and trudeau
basically sent him away empty-handed
stating in in a manner so utterly
preposterous that it's a form of idiot
miracle that no business case could be
made for canada to export liquid natural
gas to
to europe to germany in particular and
that's so utterly preposterous because
we have so much natural gas and we have
the facilities to liquefy it and the
only reason a business case can't be
made
is because the federal liberals have
made it economically impossible for any
actors to
build the pipelines for example build
the infrastructure and make this energy
accessible and so if you were leader of
the
of the provincial government in quebec
what do you think you could do what
would you be inclined to do let's say
with alberta and the rest of canada to
well to rectify that well the first
thing regarding uh oil and gas
not a few days ago i was in the sagnay
region
north northeast of quebec
to say that i'm in i'm the only
political leader right now who's in
favor of the lng quebec project which is
natural liquefied gas
uh
liquefied
project a 14 billion dollars investment
uh our quebec government initially was
in favor of it uh mr lego the current
premier even met with the the alberta
premier and he was all in favor of it
and then a few environmentalists that
stood up in montreal and mr lego
flip-flopped and decided that now he did
even worse than that he did adopt a bill
three months ago to say that in quebec
it's forbidden to explore and exploit
any kind of oil and gas
he went to the other extreme
he denied he denied the rights of the
companies who already had rights given
by the quebec government and now were
sued were sued i mean the quebec
government is sued for billions i think
it's 18 billion dollars
because we were denying rights of
companies that were given by the
government so it's it's a real mess
so he scuttled a 14 billion dollar
project yeah and then and then
accrued 18 billion dollars in potential
legal liability yeah to not produce
fossil fuel yeah just okay so
because it needs to be done
so i'm going to be environmentalist here
and i'm going to say
we need to
we need to um
transfer away from these
despicable fossil fuels as rapidly as
possible there's going to be a
substantial amount of economic
disruption as a consequence people are
going to have to bear
more costs on the energy front but
that's okay because they should be
burning less fossil fuel anyways because
of the liability accrued by the planet
these are necessary disruptions as we
move toward a sustainable economy and uh
if a few eggs have to be broken to make
an omelette than celavi
and so
what do you think about that line of
argumentation how do you how do you
respond to it how do you counter it do
you accept it
there's a few things we need to say
first off
our dependence on on on on gas and oil
is not going to stop tomorrow the
transition is going to take a few
decades actually we're even estimating
right now that for gas let's say for the
next 50 years there's going to be a
growth in terms of demand so you know
yes we're going to get out of it but
it's not going to happen overnight it
could happen in five six seven eight
decades okay so i say well that's that's
two that's too long
we're going to be roasting in our in our
oven like homes in 10 years we have to
act more precipitously and if it
requires force and fear so be it
so what why is that a problematic
argument if it is it is a you it does it
doesn't make sense in my book because
what are you gonna do in the meantime
like tomorrow morning we're 100
dependent right now in quebec of oil and
gas coming from outside okay from and so
if you know and we saw what what's
happening in in western europe right now
because they were dependent of gas
coming from russia and we see how it's
it's a it's a huge problem not to be uh
autonomous in terms of energy so in are
you proposing and the parties are always
good at currently in quebec all the
parties all the other political parties
they have goals you know and they
they're promising that they're going to
cut our our gas emission by
37.5
it's like you know it's like a an
auction to know which one is going to
have the highest percentage of cutting
uh gas emission but when you look at it
no one's ready to tell you how they're
going to do that how many factories are
they going to shut down how many million
people are going to say they can't drive
their cars anymore how many you know ski
do's and yachts and every how are they
going to do that they never ever say it
and every single time those politicians
promise that they're always lying they
never ever achieve their goal it's
always easy to look good and and that's
the problem with the left often they
want to show off well we could also
point out
we could also point out that the
americans turned radically to natural
gas fracking after the year 2000
and let's let's just outline the
consequences of that so the first bloody
consequence was that they cut their
carbon dioxide output by 15 percent
and so and that was not something that
any environmentalists predicted and
certainly would have opposed but it
turned out to be the case that well the
americans essentially made themselves
not only energy
self-sufficient but capable of then
becoming one of the world's biggest
potential exporters of fossil fuel
products they did it in a manner that
simultaneously reduced the carbon loads
and so i look at policies like trudeau's
policy and i think okay so what the
hell's the goal here exactly you're
going to demonize
liquid natural gas in particular which
is an exceptionally clean fuel which is
extremely abundant and which is also
extremely inexpensive which you think
would appeal to the lefties because
hypothetically they're compared about
the poor and instead of noticing that
and touting
liquid natural gas as a replacement for
coal and for a wood which of course the
germans are madly gathering at the
moment to the point of driving firewood
into shortage
instead of pointing out that that's a
legitimate clean and accessible
alternative that's also cheap compared
to say coal in china or coal in europe
for that matter the notion seems to be
no
we have to do something that we can't do
in an impossible manner and create panic
and economic havoc while doing it to
pretend to do something on the
environmental front that absolutely will
not happen at all it's even worse than
that they you talked about the german
delegation that came in canada a few
days ago they even came here in quebec
now they're you're right to say they're
going to have to switch over the winter
from from natural gas to to coal which
is much worse it's 60 percent more
emissions and everything like if canada
was exporting our our our lng project
with
gas we would reduce emissions so we
would do much better for the environment
and on top of creating very good jobs in
our regions here in canada but it's
worse than that we're probably going to
have to export coal because they're also
going to run out of coal so that and
that's going to be okay according to mr
trudeau's standards and the left
standards and the environmentalist
standards
the net imp you know it's all to look
good but when you you look at the data
when you look at the results it's
terrible what they're proposing it's
even worse than what they're they're
they're fighting against well let's
let's go on that looking good side so
one of the things i found out this was
also true of the conservative party in
in in ontario
and i'm you know relatively positively
predisposed to the conservatives in
ontario especially given the nature of
the alternative
during kovid and i know this because i
was told this by senior
members of the ontario
government
as well as
discussing
recently with journalist ruba subramania
and a group of people who are suing the
canadian government the court documents
have revealed for example that
the
travel ban that trudeau implemented
had
hypothetically to stop the spread of
covid had
so little scientific justification
despite being touted as scientifically
justifiable that even though the trudeau
cabinet gave direct orders to the people
working in their health departments to
formulate a scientific rationale to
justify the ban
the people so ordered
couldn't
even though that some of them were
willing to attempt the
to do so so it was it lacked such
scientific justification that even under
duress the people tasked with
generating the rationale post hoc
couldn't do it and that the reason the
bloody travel ban was implemented to
begin with which deprived about seven
million people of the right to visit
their dying relatives in hospitals for
example um
the
actual rationale was that the liberal
minority government federally headed by
trudeau
wanted to launch a precipitous election
to put themselves in the majority
position and was looking for a wedge
issue to divide canadians so that they
could ramp up their grip on power this
has all been revealed in court documents
it's it's utterly
it's utterly preposterous and and so
i i'm pointing that out as part of a
broader trend this trend of let's say
looking good well why are we
implementing a travel ban well because
we're so concerned about your health
it's like well no that's not why you
want to look like you're concerned about
our health but actually you want to you
want to catalyze your grip on power in
the most manipulative way possible but
then i also know let's say on the
conservative side when
covent policies were being formulated
and they were being touted as driven by
the science
all that was happening
was that they were
generating opinion polls that were
sampling people's fear
noting what they were most afraid of
reacting to that fear with draconian
lockdowns although not as bad in ontario
as in quebec and then post hoc
justifying that with a science that
didn't exist and then demonizing anyone
who claimed that the science did not
support that and that the measures were
overreaching it was not just federally
by the way here in quebec we went
through even worse than that with the
curfew there was not one single study
showing that a curfew is having an
impact to stop koveed actually there's
even people who and suggestions that
it's even worse because you're
concentrating more people
in in a few hours so you're they're it's
spreading faster
the and when we were asked we when the
the premier was asked for studies we
found out afterwards
that uh the the the the public health
director was trying sending notes to his
bureaucrats trying can you find me a
study just before the press conference
they were looking for and they couldn't
find one and when you they were asked
what scientific evidence do you have
that care fuse could stop the spreading
of kovid you know what they came out
with a public opinion poll that's the
science they had and they said look peop
this is what people want so
that's not science i understand there's
a methodology that is scientific but
that's about it it's political science
that's what frightened people want when
you ask ask them stupid questions that
they answer impulsively when they've
been frightened
specifically and and pointedly by their
governments in collision collusion with
the idiot legacy media that they're
subsidizing so it isn't even because
people will say well that's what people
wanted and maybe you should give it to
them it's like and this is back to that
principle of subsidiarity and
distributed political responsibility you
do not randomly sample impulsive public
opinion and derive your doctrines of
governance so i would ask you how would
you protect yourself if you were uh the
leader of the conservative party in
quebec and the premier from from falling
into that trap because i've seen people
all across the political spectrum
claim allegiance to principles but then
governed by opinion two things i want to
say for i want to go back to the oil and
gas exploitation because it's another
example of also government misusing
public opinion polls uh we've done
public opinion polls here as well and
what we see is that when you ask people
do you want quebec to exploit oil and
gas people say no no no no the majority
says no because you know they they think
we're going to pollute and block and
then when you say okay there's a war
currently in ukraine it's having this
impact on germany do you think we should
have we should send them our liquefied
gas yes or no then you have a strong
majority that's saying yes yes yes yes
yes yes so
so you have to be very cautious with the
data of those polls you can't govern by
polls because depending of how you put
the context in you're going to have
different results
you know i'm not in politics to follow
polls i'm in politics to lead polls and
i
as opposed to our government hey we we
never had a government here in quebec
that has been polling as much people
it's two three polls per day on average
that they've done over the last few
years it's crazy never they probably
pulled more in this mandate than in
quebec's history all together and
so me you know i i decided to run for a
party that was at one percent and had
500 members
uh you know i was not attracted by the
limousine or or the title or power what
you know what what drives me is my ideas
is my ideal is my is what i'm looking
for my vision for quebec for the future
and i think that's a huge difference and
people know and and they could say and i
could testify that i'm not there i'm not
an opportunist i'm and when i'm i'm
telling them i'm not telling them 50
things there i'm not going to change
quebec altogether overnight um but
there's four or five things that i want
to change uh you know i'm gonna put some
private in health care i'm gonna lower
taxes for people i'm gonna exploit and
even export our oil and gas in quebec i
will i will give more freedom of choice
to parents and the education of their
kids and even for kindergarten because
here we have a
a public daycare that is becoming almost
a public monopoly that scares me off i'm
gonna you know so there there's a few
things like that that we're gonna focus
on for the first first four years and i
think that if if we just achieve that
it's going to be huge uh yeah well even
even if you just achieved that on the
energy front i mean look at the
situation that canada is in
is that we could be rich
you know we're about 35 behind the
americans now in terms of our level of
wealth
and the
uh the
the the economic foreseers
i don't remember which group but it was
a reputable group um
estimated that of the g20 countries
canada would have the lowest economic
growth for the last for the next
four decades by which time we should be
50 or 75 percent behind the americans
when instead imagine what we have in
front of us
saskatchewan i think has more uranium
than the rest of the world combined if i
remember that correctly
we have almost inexhaustible oil and gas
reserves despite what people think
natural gas is extremely clean compared
to the alternatives particularly coal
we could we can ramp up our production
of fossil fuels in the clean and
sustainable and
moral manner that ethical canadian
businesses could offer we could make
ourselves
rich and
make our lives abundant for our children
while doing so we could provide that
energy to china so that they could be
less reliant on coal and to europe so
that the europeans would have a
diversified energy supply at a much
lower cost and so we could make poor
people rich around the world by doing so
we could
increase uh geopolitical stability
massively by differentiating our energy
supplies and
the net consequence for the environment
by the environmental standards would be
beneficial compared to the alternative
which is
well we'll destabilize things so rapidly
like we did in sri lanka that we're
going to throw people into poverty and
blow the whole
system of international trade which is
bloody well what we're risking right now
in places like europe it'll be a miracle
if the european union even
survives as far as i can tell the next
year because when the energy crunch hits
this winter which it's very likely to do
there's going to be absolute hell to pay
i mean 70 000 people were demonstrating
yesterday in czechoslovakia
so
we're playing with fire and it is this
bloody virtue signaling that says well
of course i care about the environment
and so it's time to put the forcible
clamps down on the
access that poor people have to energy
as if that's going to do anything
whatsoever except make a bad situation
worse on every possible front another
another sacred cow that we're attacking
and that's going to be of interest for
canadians outside of quebec is is
healthcare because that's another thing
that the virtue signaling is very very
important uh you know we want everybody
to have universal access free and the
best in the world and blah blah we know
the
the rest of of how they see it but the
reality is that our system is
inefficient and in quebec one of the
reasons why we had to lock down our
population more than anywhere else in
the continent is because our health care
system is probably the most inefficient
and we need to fix that and obviously
it's not some small reform within a
public monopoly that is going to achieve
that monopolies are not good it's not
efficient and we need to open up we need
to increase we need to have competition
we need to decentralize and
unfortunately
the centrally planned system that we
have right now is not good quebecers are
spending a billion dollar every single
week in a system that couldn't handle
two or three hundred patients in the
intensive healthcare for us facilities
like well did quebec build
in most of canada while the pandemic was
raging the government seemed to be
utterly unable to build more
emergency
beds
despite the fact that the pandemic raged
for a couple of years and despite the
fact that there was a tremendous amount
of money spent so what kind of
differentiated and detailed vision do
you have for
improving the health care system by
introducing some private public
diversification and why shouldn't people
be afraid of that well first off we we
have to respect the canada health act
which says says that everybody should
have could have access to free services
and it's universal so
we're going to respect the canada health
act we're not running professionally
we're running provincially but we want
to also make sure you know the the
principle is that there it's an
insurance that is public it doesn't mean
that you have to deliver the services in
a public monopoly so what we're saying
is that we already have clinics that are
private in quebec but currently it's a
hundred or zero which means uh like a
physician needs to say
to work for the public system a hundred
percent or for the private system a
hundred percent he can't he can't go uh
50 50 or 70 30. it's it's it's you're
either with us or with the enemy like
kind of thing uh we want to change that
we want to give the freedom of fit to
physicians to say look if you can't work
more than two or three days because
that's a lot of them are are stuck with
that because they don't have access to
operation facilities or all sorts of
things so then you can spend your your
extra time and go in the private sector
and give more services to the population
that's one thing the second thing we
want to say is that you can have an
insurance you can invest in your health
you know it's it's crazy in canada you
can invest to drink as much as you want
if you go to a liquor store a public
monopoly of liquor store or you can
invest you can gamble in a in a public
utility also uh with as much money as
you want but you can't invest a penny in
what's the most important in your life
and the life of your family which is
your health yeah so well so for those
who are listening some of you are going
to especially the younger people with
perhaps somewhat less experience you're
going to think well we don't want to
compromise the principle of universal
free access but let's
so my father for example um
he's been he had waited for a knee
operation he's he's an older man he's in
his mid 80s he waited for a knee
replacement for two and a half years
now one of the things i'd like to point
out is that is a cost
of course and it's lucky it didn't kill
them and so they're one of the ways that
the universally accessible free health
care system that canada hypothetically
possesses and that is hypothetically the
best in the world which is a very
dubious claim by the way is that it just
rations it and so what happens is that
as you pointed out there are nowhere
near enough operating rooms not even
close and so people are on waiting lists
for
long enough often to kill them which i
suppose is a cost savings of a sort
because they're waiting to gain access
to operating rooms that just don't exist
even though the physicians are ready to
do the operations and so you limit the
cost by just limiting access but you
don't bloody well limit the cost no you
just make it impossible for people ever
to pay enough to actually get cured yeah
and this is a there's a very pervasive
problem in the canadian healthcare
establishment
trivial problem
there's much better systems around the
world hey i visited the for example
sweden a few years ago in sweden you can
have a private hospital next to a public
hospital and the public hospital cannot
provide you the services that you need
within
a reasonable delays you can cross over
go to the private facility and the
government's going to pay for it which
makes makes more sense or even if
there's no even no matter what the
delays are if the private sector can do
it for cheaper than the public sector
you can go directly to the private
sector so
why don't we have those systems you know
europe has much more efficient systems
than we have right now in canada uh but
we're for some odd reasons we think that
our system is the best in the world but
it's not at all
and we saw it with the pandemic if you
know we saw how fast the system cracked
down and how we weren't able to to to
provide services that people were paying
for well and what are the consequences
of that too and this is partly because
the government dominated the healthcare
industry is that well
we can't actually cope with this influx
of sick people because our system is
dreadfully inefficient so what will what
do we do instead because we can't
actually offer medical services will say
well how about you don't get to go
outside
because that looks like something to do
and it looks like action on the part of
the bureaucrats or how about you can't
travel in your own country that's it and
so the degeneration and
and lack of utility of the public health
care system was a direct it was an
indirect contributor to the
authoritarian crackdown at the federal
and provincial levels absolutely and so
and you do to have you toyed at all with
the idea of because i'm always
interested in the issue of
experimentation if you were going to
transform the
the health care system in quebec by
allowing for
uh private competition and
diversification of health care provision
would you be able to do you have a
vision of how you might do that in a
manner that would be technically
experimental so that you could build toy
projects and evaluate their utility with
some half decent set of metrics before
scaling it up absolutely we'll start in
in larger cities obviously because for
for all sorts of reasons it's much more
it makes more sense because the
competition is going to be
easier to do
we're also
it looks very stupid it's a small change
but it could be a huge it could have a
huge impact currently our hospitals the
way they're funded is that they have
fixed budgets year after year and with a
few you know a few percentage increase
from one year to the other no matter how
many patients they're receiving every
year and no so
we want just to make sure that the money
follows the patient so so at least the
institution has an interest of bringing
you in and providing you services
instead of like currently the less
people come in and the better it is most
more profitable they are so we want just
to reverse the way the state funds the
system we're not going to have fixed
budgets for hospitals with a small
increase every year we're going to fund
every intervention they're doing and as
many patients more patients they have
more money they will get so at least
they're going to have an incentive even
as public institutions to attract people
and provide better services and make
sure that patients are like clients and
they want to make sure that they're
satisfied when they get out of the
hospital so next time they come to their
facility instead of the next the one
next door and so it's very small things
that could be done to send a free market
economy message that will improve the
system
any any ideas for any i'll ask you two
more sets of questions the first would
be do you have any ideas for innovations
on the education front from k through 12
to through the university system which
in my estimation has become well the
whole bloody system has become
remarkably corrupt and then also i'd
like to
uh have your opinion about we haven't
talked much about the federal
conservatives yet and the leadership
race and i'd be interested in your
what would you say your opinions and
also your hopes on that front so maybe
we can start with the issue of education
if that's a reasonable place to go
education in quebec
english canadians need to know something
the the private sector is a little bit
more present and that's also another
uh it's also another lasting uh how
could i say a thing of the past because
of the catholic church uh many of those
old schools you know they were catholic
schools and they were transformed into
private schools so we have more
competition in education in quebec than
elsewhere and the state also funds uh
public uh private institutions private
schools in quebec as high as 75
of what they do for the uh the public
sector so there's already a competition
we want to increase that and because of
that the public system has has been much
better so now they provide you know
international programs or or sports uh
and also there there's all our arts and
all sorts of activities to make sure
that they have to listen to parents
because otherwise parents go to the
private sector it has put a good
pressure and it's exactly what we want
to do in the in the health care system
we've done it at in part in the in in
schools but we want to increase it that
that a little bit more by going with
you know kind of vouchers so they could
parents could have more freedom of
choice of which school they're sending
their kids um
you know we we do believe that it's the
parents again it comes back to all the
discussion we're having since the
beginning we want to give more power in
the hands of the parents uh to decide
for the the school of their kids uh so
that's part of it but the big big issue
on education the most important one
right now is regarding daycare because
we have as i said a public daycare in
quebec uh it's called the the you know
the kindergarten of of young kids that
has been
funded by the state largely funded by
the state and there's over 100 000 kids
right now that go into that public
system
and but there's 52 000 kids that are on
waiting lists because this is what you
know states intervention does
uh it it creates waiting lists that's
how the the the cost well
yeah exactly that's where the cost is
hidden
like your father and his knee like it's
you know the cost it's not this his
credit card it's the fact that he has to
wait for over two years to get a surgery
um
so what we're saying is that this is
unacceptable and those parents pay taxes
by the way uh and they don't they cannot
they cannot have the service that
they're paying for and also with the new
reality there's more and more parents
nowadays that do not work monday to
friday nine to five the you know and
with uh some of them now are just
working two or three days outside their
homes so that what they need in terms of
daycare is very different than what
their parents or their grandparents
needed for their kids so we want to make
sure that we have a more flexible system
and obviously the state can't provide
that we need to go in the private sector
and that's why we want to give 200
per week per kid to parents who are not
within the public monopoly so they could
decide for themselves where they could
you know which kind of
of kindergarten they're looking for and
bring that to a private facility no
matter what it is so it's a voucher
system that's child-centered exactly are
you aware by any chance
um
or technical matter are you aware of any
chance of the details of the of
hungary's policy on families no i'm not
okay well let me just run that through
briefly i can send you some material i
think they've done an unbelievably
effective job um on a variety of fronts
well in hungary
um i i hope i have the details of this
exactly right but i definitely have the
picture correct so the hungarians were
very concerned about their extremely low
birth rate and i think rightly so
because i think a very low birth rate is
a sign that something has gone wrong in
the society the priorities aren't right
so are quebecers by the way i know i
know well that's partly why i'm bringing
this up so what the hungarians decided
to do and they spend about six or seven
percent of their gdp now or their budget
um i don't remember it's the budget or
the gdp but it's a large proportion of
their
governmental spending and it's the
fundamental policy objective so if
you're a hungarian mother
and this tends to be
focused particularly on people who are
within stable long-term monogamous
relationships with children
if you have four children you never pay
income tax again in your life
i think if you have three it's 75
reduction if you have two it's 50 if you
have one it's 25
and they've raised the birth rate in
hungary
substantively
they've also cut the abortion rate by 40
percent
over the last about 12 years with no
compulsion with no real change in the
underlying abortion laws and so they
have a very very family-friendly policy
and they have very very smart people
working on it and so that's
well that's that's something i found
extremely interesting and promising now
also this is so cool at the same time
they've increased female participation
in the labor force by 13
so the people who opposed the family
policy uh structure made the case that
you were going to lock women at home
and you know and revert them to a more
traditional role and this was part of
some something approximating a
patriarchal plot but the reality is is
that
women are receiving recognition for the
long-term contribution they make to to
the growth of society and its stability
and
are more able to operate in the present
and in the near future in the economic
realm
and so
so anyways i'll send you that material
i'm looking forward to read that yeah
yeah it's very it's very interesting
okay so let's close this off if you
unless there's something else that you
specifically want to address
afterward with your
with your
comments about the federal leadership
race in canada your relations
if any with the front runners and with
your hopes about what might be
accomplished you know because we could
have a conservative government in quebec
and a conservative government federally
hypothetically at some point in the next
relatively short period of time you know
next few years uh
maybe even sooner than that on the
quebec front who knows so what what do
you see
as the
appropriate and desirable way forward in
terms of your relationship with the
federal conservatives
well to talk about my personal relation
with the candidates running right now uh
you have to know that john charay who's
from quebec who's the one of the the the
the participant
in that race when a he's uh he's a
former premier so he wasn't with the
liberal party of quebec i've been a
political opponent at the provincial
level with him for uh for several years
uh i know him but i we never worked
together pierre palliev is uh who's
perceived as a front runner was a
you know was a guy that i worked with
for many years even when he was a
student uh working on stockwell days
leadership race that's when i met him
many many years ago um he even
campaigned for me when i ran for the adq
for the accident democrats quebec he was
a student working in ottawa and decided
to come for a i think he spent a month
with me campaigning on the
in my constituency where during those
days so i've known pia for ages uh and
uh so we'll see but the you know it's
not just the leader that is going to be
important but it's the direction that
the party is going to take uh that for
me is the most important um i hope that
the party is going to be nationalist no
not not just quebec nationalists but
canada nationalists because i think that
that's something's lacking in canada and
quebec right now it's not normal that
it's truckers and protesters that are
using the flag and that the the prime
minister is not like you know just the
fact that we saw that over the last few
months
should ring a bell to many people um you
know usually when you raise a flag it's
because you're supporting the
institution uh the democratic
institution of your country it's not
because you're protesting against the
people who are supposed to represent you
um
and so the uh so i hope that you know
the that's one that's gonna be one thing
that the person is going to defend our
interests nationally and that also it's
going to be a decentralist that is going
to respect provincial rights and i think
both both front runners are uh our
decentralists at a certain extent
because mr sharia was a quebec premier
so he knows how important it is for you
know he knows provinces and and their
powers
i know pierre i know that pierre is also
a strong decentralist so i think that's
very important and it's going to be
interesting and it could you know if if
there is a force provincially uh since
quebecers identified themselves more
with the provincial level than the
federal level the conservative brand in
quebec could also have a push federally
i think uh because we're you know more
and more people now are identifying
themselves as conservatives in quebec
and i'm 100 sure that it's going to have
an impact even if it's not the same
party uh you know
there's a link at many extent and people
will it's going to be much easier to
identify as a conservative so i i think
we could both help each other out but
the the opposite is also true if i do
stupid things or the conservatives at
the federal level do stupid things we're
going to impact badly each other and
have a negative overall impact yeah well
hopefully the conservatives in canada
will be able to get themselves together
on the organizational front and and be
uh useful allies rather than
counterproductive and accidental
opponents and so
are there any other
issues
i
that you would like to put before
the people who are viewing listening and
maybe also if people are interested in
supporting you
um and and helping along with this with
with the realization of your vision
what would you recommend that they do
well if they're in quebec of course they
could get much more involved they could
become member they could
give us money you know that here it's
limited to 200
per just for the election year the other
years it's only a hundred dollars we
have laws that forbid anybody but people
who have a right to vote in quebec to
give money so corporations or anyone
outside of quebec it's forbidden um and
for the uh but every single canadian
16 years old and older could become
member of the party you can go on
conservative.quebec and then you can be
a card-carrying member even if you're
outside of quebec as many quebecers as
in albertan you know that many quebecers
live in alberta nowadays because that's
where the jobs are for the oil and gas
industry since we're depriving our
people to have a right to work in that
industry in quebec um so that's one
thing they can do the uh
and the strength of the movement is also
because it's not i don't see what's
going on in quebec right now honestly as
a
as a political party it's a movement i
it's not it's not because of me it's not
because of a conservative party it's
something coming from the grassroots and
the uh there's a huge movement and those
people are
talking on the social media talking to
their neighbors their colleagues their
families
you know it's
that's the way it works and it becomes
organic right now and just commenting
and liking things on facebook is having
an impact and we see it
sharing this video right now will have
an impact uh the you know it's
we it's small little things that we
think don't change anything but it does
have an impact as much as voting well
you're you're a political operative and
you have been for a long time and you've
learned how the system works i mean it's
easy for young people in particular to
think that well there's no point for
example in joining a political party
because
they just can't
they'll just be ignored and my
experience because i've worked in
political parties is exactly the
opposite of that is that if you're
willing to commit
especially initially on the volunteer
front and you're good at it the
probability that doors will open to you
with regard to your advancement is
unbelievably high absolutely and so has
that has that been reflected in your
experience very huge and and uh and even
more than that for the upcoming election
it's the participation rate we'll have
to look at um because everything that
we're talking about and the fact that
we're talking to crowds who usually
don't even vote uh is very very
important we need to make sure that we
motivate those people and they do
you know they get out on on october 3rd
and they go cast their vote because
we're probably going to figure out the
results before we even counted one
single ballot just by looking at the
participation rate we're going to know
if we won or lost the election
and because this is all this is what and
it's not just in quebec and provincially
it's everywhere right now i think when
there's a movement like this there's a
grassroots movement if you want to know
if it's successful or not look at the
participation rate if the participation
rate is going up the roof you know that
they're winning and and in quebec last
election for example two-thirds of
voters did get out and vote so one-third
of people didn't go at all and that's
for for us it's huge because we
participate much more at the provincial
level than at the federal level that's
another difference between quebec and
canada um the uh
you know the the people are more
involved at the provincial than at the
federal level when it's time to vote and
but this time we have to look at the
participation rate and we have to
increase that so everything we're doing
and the fact that we're not in the
mainstream media is also a reflect of
that we're going outside of the normal
box of voters and so people who are
listening then we could say to them well
listen if if you want to get involved if
you're interested in the ideas that have
been discussed here and you find them in
the least compelling you could take a
risk and join a political party
the party of your choice obviously in
this case it would be the conservatives
it's not an expensive thing to do and if
you're looking for something meaningful
to be engaged in participation in the
political party can open that up to you
and then the next most important thing
or perhaps even the more important thing
given the immediacy of what's going on
in quebec is that
if you are interested in these things
and you think they're important then
please vote get out and vote yeah get
out and vote because it matters and you
know it's been the case in many
elections especially over the last
couple of decades in many countries that
the vote is actually determined by a
very small minority of people because
they're so close exactly and so while
you talk you talked about the separatist
vote in 1995 what were the what was it
forty nine point nine to fifty point one
was it that's what 49.6 to 50.4 if i
recall properly uh right right so so so
everyone's vote really did count and
more elections are like that than you
think yeah and now we have five parties
we have five parties in quebec also
which means that you don't need fifty
percent swan to win though it's
the party that's gonna win it's going to
be under 40. it's probably 30-ish
percent that is going to make a
difference and 38 of two thirds of
people not voting so it means 22
so you could lose 78 of voters and win
an election right right right right so
one of the things i've been trying to do
as i've been touring around is to
suggest to people who've become cynical
that they shoulder a bit more civic
responsibility it's like if you if you
think the system can't be changed
in some incremental fundamental and
responsible sense and you justify your
own cynicism and apathy with that
presupposition you might want to test
that out by doing something like joining
a civic organization or a political
party and what you will find is that if
you have the will the way for you will
be made way faster than you could
possibly imagine and i think that might
be more true on the political front than
in any other domain of activity because
every political party i've ever been
associated with in any way is constantly
starving for manpower work and money
absolutely
so well
it was really good talking to you today
i'm i'm um
very pleased with the fact that you
agreed to speak with me and delighted to
offer you the opportunity to delineate
your views in some
more comprehensive sense in a relatively
public square is there anything else you
would like to say to the people who are
watching and listening either
provincially federally or
internationally before we close i want
to say merci beaucoup thank you very
much it was great talking to you and
hopefully next time we can chat
face-to-face in toronto or montreal
that'd be good i'm coming to montreal in
a month and a half or so and so maybe we
can arrange to do that then i might be
premier at that time that would well
that that would make it even even uh in
some sense more exciting so um pleasure
to meet you and i hope we do get a
chance to meet in person in the
relatively near future
hello everyone i would encourage you to
continue listening to my conversation
with my guest on dailywireplus.com